hello everybody hope they are good I'm
going to try to keep this video nice and
short because I went to see an apartment
for a new potential real estate
investment and it got a bit too late so
I apologize for that I'm going to try to
explain uh myself carefully but quickly
okay so I can upload this video as soon
as possible for you I want to start uh
by um saying what we said yesterday okay
and it was this week Behavior All right
so we have here two very similar
situations
that they played out in the same way so
in this example here you can see many
weeks to the
downside okay you can see them there but
price is not breaking from this level
over here okay and that is basically
telling you that the market maker is
building his Longs and you saw yesterday
the same here yesterday's video was
pretty much about this saying that the
market maker Was preparing some shorts
to trigger a long squeeze because the
there was a lot of late long positions
that needed to be uh flush from out of
the market okay and you see the same
yesterday WS to the
upside and price not been able to break
out from this Zone it's not progressing
any further and I telling you the market
maker is building his Longs in these
weeks okay then we saw this uh Mega red
candle go to the 1 hour C to the 1 hour
time frame sorry and you see here uh
pretty much how we retrace this
liquidity pool that's what I took my
profits here okay because we broke below
the the 1 hour 50 ma like if it was buha
so my take profit was this liquidity
pool around 48,800 yeah perfect there
48,800 exactly then price uh continued
dropping a bit more it dropped another
$500 I missed that move because I
already took all my profits there and
then something that uh to be honest I
didn't expect for the day because I
thought that this move here would have
been enough volatility but you know what
the market maker said not that's not not
the case there is more to come and they
reverse price about a straight away
retrace this new liquidity pool created
there then broke out of this Zone and
continue pushing price up to
51,800 this at the moment okay so a lot
of volatility in the last uh 24 hours
more than I than I could have imagined
to be honest now in today's look this is
the indicator I'm going to show you
again okay to see what it's saying today
basically marking here the trading
sessions is something that you can um
enable or disable here okay but pretty
much is marking here liquidity pool
Tokyo held London pumped and now New
York according to the trading sessions
pattern it could reverse that's what is
telling you there all right now if that
is the case we should go to the 15
minutes time frame to to have a a deeper
look and we can see here how London
starts pretty much here uh and it's
going to finish now but as you can see
how it's leaving here some kind of
resistance Z okay that's uh this book
we're going to make it uh I think in in
white that's a resistance Z that we can
see in the chart we're still playing
around this area and there is a chance
for uh the market maker to push price a
bit higher hit all the stop losses
because I can imagine that some Traders
are starting to open new shorts so it
would make sense that if that's the real
move and new jork is going to drop today
then it would make sense first to go
higher to 52,000 52,1 100 or 200 and
then hit those stop losses and reverse
okay that's in the case that they want
to reverse but what I know is that there
is enough liquidity at
52,000 in this area to attack today
basically for that reason because the
retail Trader sees this Zone as
resistance and some people are going to
start to get nervous and say okay this
might be the top I'm going to start
dropping because in a high time frame is
true the 52,000 it's a very strong
resistance go to the weekly time frame
we talked about this yesterday sorry for
being so quick but I want you guys to
see the video um as soon as possible in
this one over here you're going to see
how this is resistance okay you can see
that that is this white box we are
entering that white box that's a
resistance Z in my opinion because here
you can see we we get to the area sell
off we get to the area we retested a
resistance in that moment another
selloff and now we're attacking this
area again and it's what I'm telling you
guys if we manage to break Above This
Zone hold above it okay that's basically
a support test then I'm be expecting
continuation all the way to 60,000 at
least possibly even to 65,000 but it's
true that 60,000 we could face some
resistance basically from this area you
guys can see this right that resistance
there between
59,000
61,000 that's another resistance okay so
yep pretty much if we manage to break
above
52k then we should hold this area
support continuation to
60,000 okay and if we manage to break
this Z of course we're going to go to my
new highs pretty quickly but the most
interested uh here is basically this
hold about 502k and we have a nice uh I
think it's 15%
pump all the way to 60k because there is
not much resistance on the way you can
see it there okay 15% move from 52k to
60k uh that's the move that I'm
interested in but obviously for that to
happen we first need to overcome this
strong resistance that I imagine is
going to be a resistance distance and
that's when the lower time frame comes
into play and we have to be careful
sorry 15 minutes time frame and we have
to be careful that New York is not going
to pull a move like this okay what
possibly here and then maybe we can
start uh to form a range here all right
so careful with that because yes if this
is resistance all this area here are
stop losses that need to get hit okay
before dropping that's what I think so I
would say that today we should go to
52,000 and then we'll see what happens
from there if we hold the area a support
expect continuation and if not uh we we
could see a spike up very fast to the
area and see a rejection to come back
into this Zone okay and then here uh we
could be forming a new
range right so that's pretty much what
I'm seeing that would be a nice uh 2%
move so yeah that's pretty much
everything based on the chart now let's
go to h capital and to the order book
the order book agrees check that out
52,000 okay um So based on the we're
going to go through high Capital to see
if there are some liquidations out the
area but based on the on the chart um I
would say that those are stop losses uh
because it matches with uh what I've
seen in the chart now let's go very
quickly to h capital B the order book
also shows a bit more liquidity to the
upside you cannot see really any red
bars to the downside right only to the
upside so careful high low Capital
liquidation levels you guys not the rule
of the channel liquidation levels first
then liquidation hit map uh what I can
see so far is that we had here that
longest squeeze that we talked yesterday
you can see that Delta dropping very
sharply back to 47 billion worth of long
liquidations again take this number with
a pinch of salt because it's not real
it's used as a reference but you can see
how uh a lot of long positions got
liquidated and those were especially
late long positions okay that's what we
were talking about that potential move
yesterday then price went back up super
fast and the Delta is still very high 21
billion that's very high so keep an eye
on for another potential longest squeeze
because that's still a lot of liquidity
there okay now liquidation hit map by
the way I'm still favoring uh that today
we go to 52,000 at least because that's
what the chart says under the book to
okay those are stop losses Z that would
make sense to go to now the liquidation
hit map we can see how yesterday we
dropped but we still had this liquidity
here you can see there
the liquidations that are hit to the
upside now in the 7 Days time frame at
least in the 7 Days time frame I don't
really see much liquidity to the upside
forming yet let's have another
look there it goes uh no not really look
at this there is not really much
liquidity forming up there yet so uh for
now we only keep 52,000 as a as a Target
and in the one month time frame let's
see if there is something new here
wow yeah there was there there was
liquidity up here okay check this
out yep look at all these yellow lines
all the yellow bars we've hit them so
yep 50 51,900 was the last uh level to
the upside now there is not really much
liquidity to the downside there is there
is quite a lot not going to lie but it's
true that the structure might be
changing and I just want to show you
that to the upsite there is not much
liquidation so so I would say that all
the liquidations targets have been hit
of course this changes uh very fast
every day and maybe tomorrow in the 7
Days time frame we see something new but
so far what I see is one Target and it's
52,000 okay a stop loss Zone that also
reflects in the order book That's All
That I Can See For Today then we're
going to see of course the reaction of
the candles at
52,000 if we drop back below the
resistance then that's when I open a
short towards 51,000 that's around 2%
move we've seen earlier uh that will
basically been a stop loss during the
New York session and a drop and that
would basically complete the trading
sessions
pattern Asia holds London pumps New York
retraces okay and uh if we see 52,000
today and price holding above that level
in in that Weekly time frame uh the uh
resistance if we holding above it and we
close at the end on Sunday that candle
uh as support above that resistance then
uh we can favor next week continuation
to 60,000 which would be insane but
that's pretty much everything that I can
see in the chart uh no not as much as
yesterday in terms of big moves uh but
come on we've had a lot of volatility
time to relax a bit right so thank you
so much for watching guys and I'll see
you soon